finalmente hubo demolición controlada no
fue una decisión sencilla pero las
dificultades en la búsqueda de posibles
supervivientes llevaron a las
autoridades a permitir al derribo me
siento aliviada porque este edificio era
inestable el edificio estaba
obstaculizando nuestros esfuerzos de
búsqueda en realidad estábamos atascados
porque no podíamos llegar a cierta parte
de la mole de escombro con este derribo
se abren nuevas posibilidades de
búsqueda ahora los rescatadores podrán
acceder a partes de los escombros antes
inaccesibles por el riesgo de derrumbe
no se descarta incluso encontrar a
personas con vida
les he oído decir que creen haber
escuchado voces en el área área donde
ahora podrán mezclar
en la decisión incluyeron también
cuestiones de seguridad pública el temor
a los vientos de la tormenta tropical
elsa también influyeron sobre las
autoridades destinando infraestructura
en pie también representa una amenaza
para la salud y la seguridad pública
dado que los vientos con fuerza de
tormenta tropical podrían haberlo
derribado de una manera que no podría
haber sido tan controlada y predicha por
el momento se desconocen las causas del
colapso del edificio un informe de 2018
detectó en él problemas estructurales
pero el alto costo de las obras provocó
que no hubieran sido abordadas por
completo otro edificio cercano tuvo que
ser evacuado el viernes tras encontrar
también fallos estructurales y
eléctricos con esta tragedia se han
encendido las alarmas
miami beach está construida sobre suelos
poco estables de arena y roca la subida
del nivel del mar por el cambio
climático podría poner en riesgo sus
cimientos